hey what's going on ladies and gentlemen
today I am here with a very special
guest I have been a fan of this man's
channel ever since I came across his
first video on YouTube and I think I
started watching Game of Thrones videos
on YouTube probably back in the
summertime and his videos were some of
the first ones that came across and
really liked and overtime after watching
a lot of his videos his channel is
actually the main reason I started to
make my own videos so he's really been a
big inspiration to me so to actually
have him on my channel is an honor and I
can't wait to get into this discussion
and get your perspective on some of
these things that we're about to discuss
Chris before we get started is there
anything you'd like to say to everybody
oh man appreciate I appreciate the the
kind words and uh thanks for having me
glad to be here on talking Thrones it's
a pleasure to have you here sir okay
everybody in this video we're going to
talk about Psalms and Aria and we're
pretty much going to give all of our
predictions about where we're going to
see these characters going in season
seven so just to kind of start I'll give
a little backstory on where we saw these
characters last and Chris I'll throw it
to you and see what you think is going
to happen to these two characters sounds
good the last time we saw Arya Stark she
was at the twins then that's when she
had the face of another woman which she
was wearing that she used to pretty much
stay undercover until the right
opportunity so that she could kill as
many phrase as possible Walder Frey
especially so basically what I want to
ask you is at the beginning of season
seven do you think Arya is still going
to be there at the twins and possibly
killing some more phrase and free and Ed
near Kali or do you think the first
scene will get with her is her just
traveling back up north yeah I
definitely think Ari has got some
unfinished business to do before she
heads home I mean we know by the season
seven filming she will get to Winterfell
at some point but I think with her being
in the Riverlands I think she she still
has to deal with Edmure Tully as you
mentioned and you know you know it
brings into question the entire thing
you know why go to Braavos to train as a
faceless assassin and you know the whole
thing with her identity the whole arc
about her identity and not knowing who
she is and you know we got confirmation
I think we both did videos on the whole
return of Nymeria and the Wolfpack for
you know so
a definitely going to be some drama
there for a while but as I've been
saying the last few videos and some QA
that it previously definitely think
she'll have to be kind of turned back to
the path you know you know family's more
important in the the real threat that
come as far as White Walkers it's almost
the the standard tragedy story right
with Aria she's she's really hard to
predict because you know the Bravo's
thing especially on the show it's kind
of complicated a bit it's a little bit
more going on in the books and it's kind
of the classic tragedy where she's a
good girl you're rooting for but she's
doing this really bad [ __ ] now even
though it's pretty much justified my
book you know I mean but yeah I think I
think we'll see her you know and her
list is shorter in the show for that
matter but I think she'll probably hang
out the Riverlands running through the
brothers without banners
specifically the Hound again I was
certainly hope to see that reunion
before she heads back north yeah I agree
her story is very hard to predict like
I've been trying to think where she's
going to end up not just at the end of
season seven but I've been trying to
think about where she's going to end up
at end of season eight I'm trying to
like actually visualize her on the
battlefield because I'm not sure what
else she would really do we know she
really doesn't want to become a lady and
have a family at least that's what she
said back in season one so I'm having
trouble visualizing her actually
becoming a wife and a mother or even on
the battlefield fighting with all the
men yeah I agree and that's what makes
her so hard to predict and talk about is
you know what is this game of her
training to be a faceless assassin
really mean you know in the books or the
show you know what does she go there for
we know was a story arc about her
identity her losing her identity she
started losing her identity very early
on and the show in books and you know
now she's back she did say last season
of course a girl is Arya Stark of
Winterfell and I'm going home but she's
going down this dark path and it makes
you question okay first of all how did
she get her faces you know if she did
she take a few you know before she left
or she had the skill now to kill people
and take their faces we haven't really
got that answer you know how does this
fit into the endgame how does not Miriam
the Wolf Pack fit it to the endgame
because as I mentioned in my of Nymeria
video you know they could have left my
Mary alone in the show right I mean
nothing like the books
hear about the the Wolfpack in the
Riverlands as you doing the books and
that type of thing so they're bringing
her back for a reason but of course
she's not a ward in the show and I don't
think they're going to introduce that
the last minute that would be kind of
insane so you know that kind of played
to the endgame a little bit is this
thing going to be something where she
simply goes on a killing spree kind of
gets talked back into understanding
what's important by the Hound or
somebody like that heads back up to find
John and her family or as this plan to
the endgame we're possibly she's the one
that takes out the night king in some
ways since she's been trained to be an
assassin so it brings up a lot of
questions and it's definitely one of the
harder characters to predict yes it
certainly does bring up a lot of
questions and something you mentioned in
there I was actually going to ask you
next do you think she's going to
continue to use that same face or do you
think she has more that she possibly
cooked from the house and of black and
white or do you think she's going to
collect more along the way up to
Winterfell yeah I would say that she's
probably collecting them as she goes I
mean I don't really know the answer that
I would just think that you know I'm
sure they're preserved well in the house
of black and white so maybe she did take
a handful but I'm just thinking she may
actually be collecting those on the way
and anybody you know I guess she's going
to probably take out anybody you know
this involved with the phrase kind of
like the Lady Stoneheart orc from the
books and so they don't necessarily have
to be on her list you know like that
serving girl she played To Kill Walder
Frey we have no idea who that is and
where that face came from so you got to
assume that perhaps she's just was
afraid of some sort of serving girl or a
wife to somebody or whatever and never
really explicitly said who that was and
how she got it so I'm guessing just this
is just my opinion that she's probably
getting the faces as she goes because we
did see her learn that skill in the
house of black and white yeah I was
wondering if she actually got that face
from the house of black and white
because at the end of season six when
they showed the shot of the wife's face
added to the wall
I'm assuming she took that face and put
the waist face up there yeah that's true
that's certainly a possibility so it
could be that we see the same the same
girl you know slip back into that face
again and that certainly possibilities
the question was was that was that spot
open that she put the waste face on or
was it just you know that she swap it
like you said so that's that's certainly
a good question yeah I have a feeling
she probably just swapped it out but I'm
not really sure exactly like you said
and um at least on the show for a
example you know it would be a lot
easier for them for her to have just one
face as well so that may make sense at
least in the show yeah absolutely right
what do you think about Jagan agar like
the way he just kind of let her leave do
you think we're going to see him come
back at all
you know honestly in the show I don't
you know obviously in the books he's got
a bigger role to play you know he's
snooping around the city right now I'm
tied in with that storyline in the show
I honestly don't think we are going to
see him again it was almost like she
went over there and the whole thing was
a test from the get-go and she just
became a service you know a you know
basically start to serve the court
unquote many-faced God and you know if
you flushed it in my videos I don't
believe they're actually any gods but he
certainly does and so you know he said
many times it doesn't matter either way
a face will be added to the hall so
basically he just gave her the tool she
needed to take out the people that you
know she had on her list in the first
place is the way I looked at it and uh
the whole damn thing was the test and
including the waste and the way floss
that tests so she absolutely right I
mean apparently we didn't see that of
course it was in the dark but uh so that
was one thing that kind of bothered me
last season was the whole candle scene
I appreciate what they did with the
whole blind Oriya thing but you got to
think the wave had that training too so
I don't think Ari would've had an
advantage there you know I mean so yeah
that's a very good point yeah you'd
think the waif would have been able to
fight in the dark as well right exactly
because in the book especially which is
of course what they're pulling from you
know they this was not a punishment it
was part of their training so you think
she had the same training I agree with
that okay uh the last time we saw Sansa
she was sitting next to Jon Snow as he
was being proclaimed king in the north
Littlefinger and songs of both exchange
that kind of like a look of concern do
you think anything is going to come out
of that that look they exchanged yeah
they definitely they're definitely going
to you know they don't waste a lot of
scenes in the show regardless
what some people think of the ship
runners you know they don't waste a lot
of scenes in dialogue so yeah there's
definitely going to be some drama there
I don't think it's going to be
over-the-top like a lot of people think
you know with between Sansa and John but
there's definitely going to be some
drama for a while little fingers
continuing his game and even though Sons
has already said basically whoo you know
I'd be a fool to trust Littlefinger when
her and John had that conversation even
though they even though she acknowledged
that and they had that conversation
which almost you know could have really
ended that right there
of course what he said guy I to her you
know the godswood he said you know who's
going to her people gonna support you
know the the true daughter of Ned Stark
or some bastard you know born in the
south so she undermined that again you
know her confidence with with John and
there's there's going to be some drama
for sure it's not going to be this clean
and you know that's the thing he's going
to take off go Sal you know Danny's
going to arrive I'm assuming and sent
and sent out Ravens to all the lords and
that would include John Ben King in the
north so she's going to get a little
taste of what it is to rule there for a
while and we'll see if she likes it
after all yeah absolutely I have a
feeling as soon as John leaves for
Dragonstone that's when Littlefinger is
going to begin his game again and start
putting more stuff in Santa's head to
try to get her to continue to turn
against Jon exactly I think that's
exactly what's going to happen he's
going to continue to play that game and
that will bring in later on you know
we're talking about audio of course -
that'll bring in REM brand to the whole
picture - as far as you know realizing
what the hell he's actually doing even
though he's basically told Sansa and
that's where he [ __ ] up you know he
gave away his game he told Sam to his
end game do you think Sean's is going to
stay at Winterfell for the entire season
I would imagine she would I could see
her in a sense maybe heading back to the
Vale at some point if we bring sweet
Robin back into it and depending on you
know the the amount of drama between
Littlefinger and her and what he stirs
up I could see her possibly going there
but at this point I really don't see her
leaving unless as it is the Vale you
know with something - a sweet Robin
there's some kind of marriage
arrangement or whatever because although
she's aware of the problem with Jon
right and the White Walkers and the real
threat she's aware of all that she still
she still got a little bit of this you
know kind of Cersei and
a little bit where she wants to be queen
so bad you know and she's and that's
what little fingers kind of bringing out
at her although she was she was starting
to kind of go back to uh carrying about
that type of thing and family was more
important but you know little finger
again has kind of twisted the series so
if that makes sense
yeah it certainly does little finger is
probably the best manipulator in the
show and songs is kind of like one of
those characters who has been easily
manipulated so it's kind of like a
double-edged sword for senses is the the
kind of the stork you love to hate at
times you know in the very beginning she
was very much a brat you know I want to
be queen that's all that matters in the
world and then she went through her you
know the stuff she did with Joffrey and
especially Ramsay and you felt horrible
for she certainly didn't deserve that
but now little fingers with her is
manipulation it's kind of bringing that
back out of her almost a Circe esc' type
character right you know she still got
this little lust for power even though
she knows the real problem the real
threat to come from the doors as far as
the White Walkers so it's a like I said
are en Santa there they're two people
that it's hard to predict those type of
things because they're not you know but
they very much play a role in the end
game I think so it's it's hard to say
but definitely gonna be some drama
absolutely right I'm kind of hoping
songs it does take some action in season
seven and tries to take control of the
Vale army one way or another whether
it's getting rid of Littlefinger
completely or talking to sweet Robin and
getting him into the fold getting him to
support John himself instead I have a
little finger make all the decisions
yeah I agree and I do think that you
know it's going to come down to I do
things little finger to make a little
prediction here I think he's got to go
it's the N season seven you know at
least by the end of season seven I mean
she's in and that's what I was saying if
I see her leaving Winterfell at all I
think it is going to be - back to the
Vale perhaps or whatever to take control
of that there's certainly something
there with Robin you know they've had
them together in previous scenes in
previous seasons so if she if she does
leave Winterfell is definitely going to
be a political movement over to -
probably head to the Vale and uh pretty
much take control of little Robin so we
know John definitely needs to bail
forces for
when the White Walkers actually do come
marching down south yeah he's going to
get everybody he possibly can and he
will reach out to his enemies the
Lannisters included so I'm sure we'll
see that as well oh you think so he's
going to reach out to the Lannisters
yeah I don't think that uh I don't think
that John is going to be this you know
he's the he's the the figure right he's
the prince that was promised tours or
'hi in the sense that not like I said
I've said in many many videos on my
channel I do not believe in a literal
flaming sword I think that's all
metaphorical but you know he's trying to
do the right thing and he knows that the
right thing is to save the realm and I
think he would even try to reach out to
through the Queen in King's Landing now
so to speak you know if he had to make
them understand and I think we've got
you know some filming news and plot
leaks of course that you've talked about
in your channel I think and I think that
kind of leads that direction where
they're going to have this this meeting
and I think that's probably part of it
yeah it's a very good point we could see
John try to reach out to them at that
big parlay scene at the end of season 7
if that is in fact true yeah we might
see that yeah I mean that's that's his
main focus I don't he doesn't care about
being King in the North I mean he's
always wanted that especially in the
book you know he dreamed of being a
stark and bring dreamed of being the
Lord of Winterfell and that type of
thing and uh buddy anyway you know with
this with this new threat you know
that's all he cares about and it was
pretty much foreshadowed with the
wildlings you know that's what he wanted
to do he went to the enemy so to speak
which was really just you know a
different group of people that live them
you know the wrong side of the wall so
to speak and and got them down there
they got killed for it so I think he'll
continue that kite type of you know
reaching out to people regardless yeah I
think you're absolutely right that's
interesting to think about it's kind of
hard for me to wrap my head around John
and Cersei ever having a civil
conversation but I'm wondering if it's
actually true with what the leaks I said
Circe's response is actually going to be
I'm wondering if she's really going to
turn her back to the threat like that
yeah I don't I don't know about the
leagues but you know just my guess you
know I think sir she can't have a
dialogue with him do I believe she
actually cares no absolutely not she'll
chill try to screw somebody over every
plan she's ever made goes to [ __ ] she'll
try something else
I'm assuming it's going to be another
wildfire trick you know with the red key
perhaps this time and we'll get into
that when we talk about you know the
whole Danny versus Circe thing on my
channel but anyway I think she'll listen
or at least pretend to listen but I
can't see we're actually giving a damn
here you're probably right I agree with
that okay out of touch back on Aria I
have a feeling Aria is going to run into
several characters on our way back to
Winterfell I think she's going to see
Melisandre again and possibly even to
hound on our way home plus it's looking
like we may see Nymeria again to which I
have felt we would for a long time now
which I've said in several previous
videos do you think Aria will run into
anyone along the way and what could you
see happening if so yeah I agree I do
think she's going to run into Melisandre
we we saw I believe in you know previous
season you know we will meet again for
Melisandre and uh you know she told her
she was going to shut you know these
eyes forever and I think that uh you
know I don't not to necessarily predict
Melisandre death but I think if that
happened in season seven it's probably
going to be Arya she is going to before
she gets turned back to the important
things like her family and the war to
come when she finds out the truth I
think she could very well run to
Melisandre and hear about Jon from her
before she kills her if she does at all
so I definitely think she runs into
Melisandre again and the Hound for sure
and the Brotherhood because uh she may
take a little bit of the Lady Stoneheart
thing but you know they're going to
basically be the one to say look we're
heading north here's what's really going
on and Melisandre could be the actual
person to say your brother's back in
Winterfell with your sister you need to
head up there there's something more
important going on so definitely yeah
that's what I was wondering I was trying
to think of a way Melisandre could avoid
being killed by Arya if they do confront
each other and I'm wondering that would
Melisandre know that Arya is related to
Jon yeah hard to say I know she could
she could kind of avoid that by taking
off for a little uh her brooch and
taking her promotions you know that's
certainly a way she can sneak around as
a so-called faceless man - right so you
know but I don't I think MELAS
when it comes down to her you know she's
mentioned several times she's very very
old right we found that out obviously
that got confirmed last season you know
she's ready to die she's carrying the
world on her shoulders you know she's
done some bad things but she really
honestly believes that everything's on
her shoulders and this is the way it is
in the books as well she honestly
believes she's doing the right thing
when she burns these people alive for
the greater good so to speak so I could
see I can almost see a scene where you
know she gets you know stabbed or
shanked or something by Aria and in her
dying breath she tells Aria the truth
about John being home and the wars to
come and all that so I could see
something like that going down actually
yeah I'd be pretty damn cool to see
actually I believe I don't remember the
description the book so we'll but you
know she said in her scene you know
green eyes blue eyes brown eyes it's
gonna shut forever
I believe Melisandre has blue eyes right
I'm not sure I know sir she has green
eyes but I can't remember everybody's
eye color to be honest right yeah I'm
not sure what's the big thing in the
book you know and that's one of George
RR Martin's problems he can't remember
the eye color she described a previous
chapter so that's why he has Elio again
when to write so yeah I deal no reason
why I even remember sir seasons because
they would say it sometimes it would
look like wildfire yeah exactly and but
you've been again talking about the show
you can't go by looks because they
completely miss you know they didn't
really worry about the details of
everybody there obviously so you can't
go by character descriptions in the show
as far as the end game so yep absolutely
right what are your thoughts want to
start reunion next season do you think
we will see Arya Sansa bran and John
altogether at Winterfell at the same
time next season yeah I think that's
going to be a little bit of a
bittersweet thing in and of itself I do
think we'll see Sansa Brand and Arya but
I don't think Jon's going to be there I
think he's going to leave probably right
before they you know show up so you know
Jon's going to take off go see Danny in
the south and had to Dragonstone I'm
assuming based off you know filming news
and things like that so I think he
leaves and leave Sansa you know
basically Lady of Winterfell before he
takes off and
then of course bran will show up after
John leaves only to leave us hanging you
know because he wants to tell John the
truth of course that brings into
question how I read and all that stuff
but the point being yeah I think it's
going to be where they kind of just miss
John because they've done this so many
times especially with bran in previous
seasons you know he's been right there
he's been right there within 15 20 yards
of him you know two times now and never
saw him you know face to face never knew
is there so I think that'll probably
happen again although we will see a
little reunion with Brandon Arya and
Sansa yeah absolutely agree I think
they're going to tease the reunion
between John and brandy entire season we
probably won't get that reveal of bran
telling John what he's seen and probably
until season 8 yeah I'm thinking that's
probably what it's going to go down and
of course I've questioned that too and I
actually thought about a separate little
video and that as well is you know this
bittersweet thing will John ever find
out you know but I think you will but
you know it's just certainly a question
I could sort of see that happening but
yeah I don't think it's going to happen
this season and Plus you know that that
brings in the question Howland Reed you
know they did introduce him on the show
the tower droid flashback obviously he's
going to be very important in the blows
we've heard from George our Morton
himself that you will be back so yeah I
don't think it's going to happen this
season either I would like to at least
at the end maybe possibly because that
maybe set up the end game maybe he has
to find out what he has to actually do
and as to his lineage so I don't think
it's going to happen but I sure would
like it to yeah you actually just kind
of broke my heart there for a second
when you said John may never find out
about his parents I thought oh god
please don't do that to us
yeah till wouldn't would that not be
bittersweet more than just a few people
dying I mean seriously
oh man friend I never find out something
that big if they would tease that for
the entire series always right exactly I
mean you know like I said that's the
reason I think he probably will find out
but at the same time you know all this
buildup in the books from from the very
first chapters in the first book a game
of Thrones and the TV show obviously
with the with the hints we've gone down
here that the audience as the viewer you
know but then John never finds out an
actual
wouldn't that be [ __ ] bittersweet oh
that would have to really suck I would
hate that I hope that doesn't happen
exactly exactly okay now with Sean's a
do you think she's actually going to get
married in season seven because I've
been seeing some theories and videos
going around there were people actually
believe that songs is going to marry
Littlefinger in season seven do you
think she's not only going to marry him
bud
anybody next season I don't see that
actually I see her you know possibly
thinking about it you know because she
is like I said you know little fingers
got her back on this Queen kick again
and I think she certainly would consider
that but I don't think she actually do
it if anything if you want my you know
my personal it's kind of a want more
than a prediction but if you want my
personal prediction for the endgame of
Sansa I see her interior get back
together it's some point I could see
that too honestly and I want to remind
not at all I wouldn't mind that you know
I could see at the end of this thing you
know Tyrion sitting there with the very
people where they're going to be left
because it's going to be a lot of
corners there's going to be a lot of
people going that we loved on the show
and in the books for that matter I could
see him sitting there sipping empty
delight right with his wife Sansa you
don't I mean I agree I think Karen's
going to play a major role in the end
game when it comes to rebuilding
basically Westeros and humanity I think
he's going to be one of the key figures
and doing it yeah I think so then I
could see I can see that happening you
know because you know she learned that
Tyrion was not a horrible person
regardless of his last name and of
course her and Margaery their
conversations in King's Landing and you
know she definitely respected Tyrion for
not you know consummating the marriage
and all that kind of stuff and and so I
could see that where she because you
know her whole thing this whole time has
been you know having this perfect prince
right you know to marry this perfect
prince whether that was Joffrey or Loras
or whatever and then to marry an imp
would just be a fitting into that story
you know me and Marjorie also let Shawn
to know that big things come in small
packages exactly exactly and that's why
I think that's the possibility actually
is those conversations yeah I could
absolutely see that going down and if
she had to marry anybody that's who I
would want it to be yeah I agree I agree
100% okay now if Littlefinger is still
at 1fl when aria arrives what kind of
problems do you foresee considering aria
knows that Littlefinger was in cahoots
with Tywin
yeah that's exactly what's going to
happen I think is you know Aria kind of
knows the deal with with his backstory
you know nobody really knows that and he
was the one to betray Ned and literally
hold a knife to his throat Aria was
there with Tywin ari was there when
Littlefinger came in and tried to hide
herself because he would recognize her
so he knows and that's what's going to
change sanz's mind about this thing
again you know got to get her back on
the right track so she's been put in so
many different directions it's not going
to be an easy like okay yeah I believe
you right up front but that's that's
going to be part of the drama and
getting her back on to understand it
he's just using you he's using your name
you know he's he's told you your endgame
that you know his endgame now so I think
that's definitely part of his aria
telling Sansa look this is what he
actually did and you know she had no
idea yeah and as much as I love
Littlefinger's character like I can't
wait to see for that data actually come
and him to finally face the music for
all the things that he has done exactly
and I could see that going down in many
ways we know whether that's bran or
whether that's Aria or self you know I
would like to think I said in the QA is
that I did on my channel I would like to
see Littlefinger go out the [ __ ]
window in the old tower yeah I remember
you saying I don't Channel oh yeah I
mean I think you know yeah Jaime would
be you know I like Jaime I don't want
him to die but so people could say you
know it would be fitting for him to go
out at the end or something like that as
far as even though he's been redeemed
and sort of a way and he probably will
be even more before he dies if he does
but a little fingers started all this
[ __ ] you know Littlefinger basically got
all this started people acted on it like
I said many times Catelyn you know acted
on this whole thing with a dagger
without any real proof but it was all
his setup you know so I could see that
being poetic justice him going find out
the damn window just like bran did so
yeah it's definitely Littlefinger's
fault that Ned even ended up in King's
Landing in the first place with him
plotting to kill Jon Arryn exactly him
that was the whole setup in the first
place killing Jon Arryn to get Ned up
there so they could start a war between
the the lions and the wolves
absolutely right what else do you see
Aria doing next season I feel like she's
going to go home obviously but I don't
see her staying there for the entire
time she definitely wants to see her
family again but she isn't going to just
sit around and be a Susie Q homemaker so
what kind of a role can she actually
play with all the upcoming Wars on the
horizon yeah I think that would be you
know and I don't know like I said you
may know more than me if you've done
some some supposed to script leaked
stuff and all that but I would I would
think that she would the majority of the
season she would be in the Riverlands
heading north or whatever you know
meeting up with the Brotherhood the
Hound you know finishing her her issue
with the phrase perhaps dealing with
Eddie or totally in the Riverlands all
that good stuff so I would think it
would be more of an end the season or
closer then to see the thing when she
gets to Winterfell
the Dench of course gets tied up in the
the Sam's that Littlefinger drama so I
that's honestly what I see her doing
this season is it's kind of almost a
half-and-half type thing if you want to
say that so you know half of her story
is is the Riverlands plot lines they're
kind of wrapping that stuff up and then
her getting home and you know we got the
looming war for the dawn right with Jon
and everybody trying to ride a realm but
kind of finishing off the political [ __ ]
with Littlefinger so yeah I can't
actually see that because it's so hard
for me to picture seeing Arya just kind
of sit around at Winterfell so it
wouldn't make much more sense for her to
be traveling to Winterfell for most of
the season and getting all those
reunions with the Hound elisandra and
things like that
exactly exactly do you think any of the
stark sisters are going to kill any main
characters next season do you think Arya
is going to kill anybody else on her hit
list
other than Melisandre well really in the
show you know she only really has
Melisandre and Cersei lives she's
basically taking the handoff right I
mean I guess you know sir Ilyn Payne is
still on there but what I'm saying is as
far as the scene was repairing the waif
when they were still doing the training
she only named two peoples in you know
and she had like forgotten half her list
even though half woman been killed you
know in other ways so I you know
I would like to see her certainly take
out like you know for the whole valonqar
thing right but that wasn't really in
the show either so it could be anybody
to kill search in the show so that's
certainly a possibility that hurt you
know she wants to head to King's Landing
before she meets up with the Brotherhood
or the Hound or whatever and she decides
to go to Winterfell instead so you know
that may be a season 8 thing or whatever
but if anybody I definitely think
Littlefinger you know like we just
talked about I think she could be the
one to do him in you know maybe uh using
her skills when she does get back to
Winterfell after she gets involved with
the drama with Littlefinger and Sansa
and she may decide for Sansa that you
know he needs to be taken out so if
anybody I would say I would say
Melisandre perhaps Littlefinger as far
as the start start keel so to speak
Sansa you know she's not going to swing
the sword herself but I could definitely
see her you know with the little finger
that would be the other option with him
you know or during his death via Brienne
or something like that so yeah I can
definitely see that yeah just start to
play the game right she's got to start
playing this game she's been teasing
this for two seasons now but about
becoming dark Sansa of us you needed to
actually do it yeah they can't keep
knocking our character back like she
needs to continue to rise
exactly exactly otherwise just kill her
all right yeah then what's the point of
having her around exactly there's
something else someone asked you I have
one more question but since we was just
talking about arias hit list I actually
just thought of something
um I've seen a lot of things go around
on the internet talking about how Aria
could potentially kill Cersei and I've
seen people say she could possibly wear
Jamie's face now is it can confirmed
that when she wears somebody's face she
actually takes on their size to like
their body shape no that's one thing
that's really still a mystery we would
just talk about this in a Q&A as a
matter of fact on my channel where
somebody that asked that very question
for my understanding and I don't know
the really specific details and I don't
remember if I read this and the world of
Ice and Fire this is a long time ago but
there seems to be different levels to be
the magic involved with faceless men you
know you have the regular you know kind
of a glamour type magic right kind of
like Melisandre where you know use some
object like a ruby
perhaps to glamour yourself but it
really only works on certain people for
a certain amount of time or something
like that and then a level two so to
speak was the actual face you know the
actual basically a mask and then perhaps
there's a third level where they can
change the bone structure or get taller
or shorter I don't necessarily buy that
but we really don't know I think that's
the thing that's you know that's the
thing needs to be explained on how that
works you know if she for example takes
uh you know somebody's face at River
let's say if for example she takes water
phrase face I mean is she going to all
the sudden become taller and fatter
he doesn't means so that was exactly my
point because I mean with her wearing
Jamie's face I don't know Jamie's exact
height but he looks like he's over six
foot tall so how would she pull that off
exactly and that's the question we
really just don't know we don't know
today I mean at least to my knowledge I
don't know of how this actually works
the whole thing it's really explained
that well in the books
I'm I'm not even sure where I remember
hearing about the three different levels
so from honestly so yeah it's just it's
hard to say I can't see I can't sit but
of course they do take the bone
structure in the face so you know MAGIX
magically doesn't explain anything with
that so but just going it magic so you
know however they do it you know I don't
know I don't but there's really no
clear-cut answers as far as I'm aware of
how this magic works and does she get
taller you know I mean I for example
could she take the the face of the Mount
I'm right I mean that would be a stream
she's very sure he's very tall I'll be
too I even if he had to she had to face
that'd be pretty damn obvious it was
good he went quite tall enough I don't
think that's going to work that well I
think it's for short little stance to
infiltrate something you know that type
of thing that's really all I can see it
work it is yeah I completely agree I
don't think she would be taking on the
size of the person either I think she
pretty much has to take the face of
somebody that has a similar build to her
you're right right to be effective
anyway yeah absolutely
speaking of water afraid did you see
that he was recast for season seven I
did I did hear that and I think it's got
to be a funeral scene right or some kind
of funeral scene I mean really like just
like Tywin did you know
that's exactly what I was going to say
because some people have thought that
she may be using his face and I think
it's exactly going to be what you just
said it's just going to be a funeral
scene or maybe even somebody discovering
his body in the little dining hall right
exactly so because we may not even see
if you know same because by the time she
gets done there you know it at the twins
there may not be anybody to give him a
funeral so yeah it could be something
where he's just found laying there over
the table yeah that's exactly what I
think it is I don't think she's going to
be wearing his face no I don't I don't
think so either
thank you right okay so one last
question and pretty much the biggest
question I want to ask you before we end
this video will either one of those
stark sisters die during season 7g see
Sansa or Rea die in this season I don't
think so I mean I think if I think we
may have to lose one more start before
this thing ends at least one more stark
and I could make cases for anybody
really honestly brand Sansa or Aria but
I don't think this season we will if I
had to if I had to choose I mean I think
I think Aria has got the bigger endgame
role obviously John does and obviously
bran does so I would think if anybody
could be you know killed off it would be
Sansa if that has to happen I don't
think it happens at season seven but I
think that's certainly a possibility
although slim yeah I completely agree I
don't think they're going to kill any
one of them off just yet it kind of
feels like all the Starks are going to
be around until at least season eight
and if any of them more do diets
probably going to be in one of the last
episodes either episode 5 or 6 in season
8 you're right yeah I agree I agree
okay Chris well I think we pretty much
covered all the main things that these
characters are going to be going through
next season um if there's anything else
you'd like to say about them before we
sign off
feel free no I think that's it I think
we covered quite a bit here I think
we've been going on for now what over
almost 40 minutes here so yeah I think
we uh I think we had a few good points
there yeah absolutely uh I appreciate
you coming on I really enjoyed this
discussion I hope everybody listening
enjoys this as well if you guys aren't
subscribed to Chris's channel
smokescreen yet please go over and do
that he has a ton of content hours and
hours of stuff you got
can listen to I've pretty much watched
all of his videos so I know if you guys
are anything like me which you all seem
to like the same game of thrones related
material as I do you're going to love
all his videos to definitely go over
this channel and check all his stuff out
and Chris I appreciate you for being
here I had a great time talking about
these two characters with you and
hopefully in the future we can do this
again yeah I appreciate you having men I
enjoyed it and always a lo talking Game
of Thrones Song of Ice and Fire
regardless I could talk all night about
it so thanks for having man and yeah
appreciate it enjoyed it absolutely and
one last thing me and Chris are also
going to record another video after this
it's going to be a Dany verse Cersei
video so as soon as you see this video
up more than likely he's going to have
his up too so head over one to his
channel and definitely check out that
video that we're going to make about Dan
Ivar Cersei yep we'll do that next and
yeah we'll try to release these I
believe at the same time as what we get
planned so yeah definitely out and maybe
a two-parter I don't know we will have
to see how long we talk about that but
uh we'll definitely have that up and at
the same time so uh yeah I enjoyed it
yes sir
Chris thanks for being here and
everybody else I will see you guys down
in the comment section bye